explain something to me you say when you
started to play drums you know you
didn't have a drum kit and stuff you
would play on pillows and things like
that
and then you said um i do this thing
and it actually i used to have to go to
the dentist would ruin my teeth i would
play the drums on my teeth any and you
said the only other guy you ever saw
play the drums on his teeth
or with his teeth was kurt cobain that's
how he taught himself drums
i didn't really in other words i've
tried to imagine what you're talking
about is it this
yes but it sounds like this okay listen
it's like
it's like that wow
and and that's how you taught yourself
like that was one of the things you did
and you say even when you were drumming
for nirvana back then you saw kurt
moving his teeth
to keep pace or to keep a beat going
right yeah like if you watch the
unplugged uh footage that we shot um you
can kind of see his jaw moving back and
forth and he would sort of use that as a
metronome to like keep time whenever he
was
like playing something and you know what
i've learned after like sharing that
with some people is that a lot of
musicians do the same thing and i think
what happens is
um when you discover music and you start
getting really into it
uh it's a second obsession and so
whether you're like just playing drums
on a table
or you're humming something in your head
you're basically just
you know you're kind of utilizing any
resource to do it and when you're a kid
and you don't have a drum set you know
and and and you're playing learning on
pillows i would walk to school with my
backpack and just place songs with my
teeth until i got to my locker and then
i'd throw my backpack in the locker and
the day would start but yes i went to
the dentist and he was like did you chew
a lot of ice i was like 10 11. yeah i'm
like no why he goes he was like your
mouth your teeth have an unusual amount
of deterioration
and i was like oh wait i could play
drums with my teeth and i made him
listen to me do it and he was like get
the [ __ ] out of my office right now that
is the stupidest thing i've ever seen in
my [ __ ] life